PET scan is clear. What does this physiological
avidity throughout mean?
So I think you're asking a question about when the radiologist
says physiology, physiologic
avidity throughout meaning that he that just I believe means that he's able to
see what he was looking for.
So if everything is clear on your PET scan
nothing is nothing is lighting up on the PET scan, that's a good thing.
But just like we talked about and I not trying to burst a bubble,
but I just want to say this is just one test.
So don't I think people have made the mistake of listening to their
oncologists and say, oh, great, your cancer free.
And then, you know, they can let down their guard and not treat
themselves as if they have cancer and not that we want to ever
act in fear or anything like that, but we also want to act in wisdom.
So we don't let out our trust in our heavenly Father that he is the one
healing us, the one who who is sustaining us.
And I know you who are asking this question, who would never do this
anyhow, but you're keeping your faith in him that he's going
to continue to sustain every physiological process every every millisecond
of the day.
So that's great news.
It's fantastic news, but we keep up the course.